[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la deuxième
édition du digiworld ex c'est un
événement annuel qui célèbre l'action de
l'écosystème d'innovation sur saclay les
dj rôle d'ace c'est un événement qui est
orienté aux entreprises surtout à
l'industrie avec lesquelles travaillent
les instituts de recherche tout
l'écosystème d'innovation de saclay que
ce soient des grands groupes ou des pme
lors de cet événement les industriels
les laboratoires les instituts de
recherche montre les innovations qu'ils
ont produit ensemble lors de la dernière
année que ce soit des robots nouveaux
produits nouveaux procédés du logiciel
cette année il y a quelque chose qui a
changé fondamentalement par rapport à
l'année dernière et c'est la position de
10 j cole dans l'europe et dans le monde
l'année dernière l'événement a rassemblé
des acteurs de l'écosystème régional
cette année dit j cole est en rade
l'innovation digitale européen au centre
de certaines des initiatives les plus
importantes à l'europe pour changer par
exemple le manufacturing
c'est le cas du led quartet de ligeti
manufacturing une communauté de 50
acteurs industriels académiques européen
qui va changer la façon dont on innove
dont on forme les gens et dont on crée
des entreprises dans les transforme dans
le manufacturier en europe et beaucoup
d'initiatives comme celle là qui ont
démarré ces dernières années comme par
exemple le réseau européen de digital
innovation rab à l'intelligence
artificielle donc des girolles ferez
partie
pour nous l'initiative des girolles et
clé dans un moment comme celui qui nous
vivons aujourd'hui où l'intelligence
artificielle est en train de faire
bouger les lignes
pas seulement des technologies mais
aussi de l'industrie et aussi de la
société la seule façon de survivre c'est
de se mettre ensemble en tant
qu'écosystème de ramener l'industrie le
milieu académique le monde de la
recherche mais aussi le grand public
pour faire des innovations avec des
valeurs derrière connecter à d'autres
écosystèmes ailleurs et pouvoir
continuer à avoir un poids et à exister
dans un monde qui bouge de plus en plus
vite
[Musique]